"Хатинка пекаря" - нині єдина пекарня в Бучі.
Під час окупації працівники виїхали, але тепер відновили роботу.
Секрет їхнього хліба - у справжній печі й старовинному рецепті.
Це опара на білий хліб: борошно, закваска, трішки дріжджів і цукор.
Дріжджі додаються для швидкості, це не обов'язково, якщо є багато часу.
Потім замішується тісто, і воно повинне три рази вистояти по пів години.
В тісто ще додається олія, сіль і борошно.
Ароматні буханці можна взяти безкоштовно або ж залишивши пекарні добровільну пожертву.
Для багатьох жителів району "Хатинка" - єдине місце, де можна дістати хліб.
Хліб беремо, бо магазини в Рубежівці не працюють, у Забуччі не працюють, тобто хліба ще немає де купити.
Ось така ситуація. Їздимо сюди поки. Дякуємо хлопцям, що тут працюють і роблять для нас хліб, випікають.
Хліб смачний, ми до війни тут завжди брали. Молодці хлопці, такий він домашній-домашній.
Під час окупації "Хатинку" понівечили обстріли.
Усередині жили російські військові.
Вони понищили холодильники, викрали пекарське обладнання і продукти, розповідають пекарі.
Після звільнення Бучі місцеві жителі допомогли поставити вікна, зібрати кошти на генератор.
Перші дні взагалі було складно, ми возили воду з Києва, води взагалі не було.
Привозили просто в бутлях. І так як пічка на дровах - це був великий плюс, бо ми могли випікати без світла,
без електроенергії, продовжувати готувати хліб.
Ми тут готували в темряві, зі свічками, з налобними ліхтариками, спали на цих столах, просто в пекарні.
З борошном, дріжджами, олією допомогли волонтери.
Ось ці пакунки - з Польщі, їх доставив власник пекарні у Познані.
У "Хатинці" щодня випікають по 300 буханців. Частину безкоштовно віддають волонтерам.
Тут 50, так? Щось мало. Там напишеш на Вайбер на цей номер, що треба, - я привезу.
Аби випікати вдвічі більше хліба, "Хатинка пекаря" планує розширення.
У соцмережах збирають кошти на ще одну піч.
Димом і свіжими пиріжками пахне і на цьому подвір'ї в житловому кварталі.
Тут досі працює польова кухня.
Будинки довкола - з побитими вікнами, пошкодженими дахами, в деяких квартирах неможливо жити.
Поруч, у будівлі денного стаціонару, розташований центр допомоги.
Сюди волонтери збирають хліб, продукти й медикаменти, які привозять з інших регіонів.
Разом із теробороною вони працювали тут до середини березня.
Коли ми поранених приймали, то ми їх тут не могли оперувати, бо вікно не могли зашити.
А тут зашили ми коврами і оперували просто на підлозі, матраци спускали зверху.
Нині в колишньому рентген-кабінеті - продуктовий склад.
Звідси продовольство доставляють по навколишніх селах.
Там ситуація з продуктами ще гірша, ніж у місті.
Якщо прибрати Бучу - на сьогоднішній день вона нагодована - але регіони, що знаходяться далі, дальні села, вони залишаються голодними.
Туди не доїжджає жодна допомога. Через те ми намагаємося їздити і роздавати.
Нині в Бучі про пекло війни нагадують зруйновані будинки й кладовище прострілених автомобілів.
А про понад 400 загиблих мирних жителів - міський цвинтар.
І все ж, до міста масово повертаються люди.
На вулицях навіть з'являються затори.
Комунальники запевняють, що світло, вода і газ відновлені в 99-ти відсотках осель.
Поступово відчиняються магазини, банки.
Цей будівельний гіпермаркет - зруйнований. Але він працює - видає інтернет-замовлення.
Руїни магазину охороняє Григорій. Його пост - стілець посеред порожньої парковки.
Нині місія сторожа - не пускати цікавих подивитися, що під завалами.
Конструкція нестабільна, всередині можуть залишатися нерозірвані снаряди.
Коли ми були під час бойових дій на робочому місці, до нас спочатку залетіла ракета, але вона не вибухнула.
В центр техніки, там, де телевізори, комп'ютери, побутова техніка.
Потім міна у 80-ий відділ трохи далі, де сантехніка та дерево.
Потім ставало все спекотніше і спекотніше.
З цього ж місця чоловік спостерігав, як росіяни руйнують Київщину.
Мені було звідси видно, як вони стріляють по Ірпеню, по висотках.
Дім стоїть - не горить, вони стріляють, поки він не загориться.
Загорівся - стріляють в наступний.
Чоловік не виїхав з Бучі. Залишився доглядати за старенькою матір'ю.
5 березня від робочого місця Григорія залишилися руїни.
Наступного дня така ж доля спіткала його будинок.
Влучило в кухню, з якої чоловік з мамою вийшли за мить до "прильоту".
Залетіла міна. Зразу такий вибух, у вухах задзвеніло, пилюки повний дім.
Потім інший був вибух після цього. Ми заховалися в підвал.
А потім, коли вже стрілянина закінчилася, ми вийшли з підвалу й побачили,
що сусідський будинок весь осколками побитий, у цеглі дірки, таке враження, що вони наскрізні.
Я підійшов до вікна, а там сусідка наша, тьотя Дуся, на ліжку лежить вся в крові.
Потім ми зрозуміли, що вона мертва. Поховали ми її у неї у дворі.
Григорій з семи років живе в Бучі. А сам родом із села Семигори - батьківщини "Кайдашевої сім'ї".
Тож навіть після всього пережитого не втрачає оптимізму.
І вірить, що його Бучу відбудують. Головне - аби кожен виконував свою роботу.
Вона буде краща, ніж раніше. Все буде добре. Все відбудуємо. Все буде Україна, як-то кажуть!
Цей будинок в Бучі саме відбудовують після російських обстрілів.
На городі й клумбах - вирви від снарядів.
Після одного з "прильотів" оселя лишилася без даху і змокла всередині.
Тут жила бабуся, виїхала, здається, першим "зеленим коридором", дев'ятий-десятий день.
На наступний день прилетів снаряд сюди. Побило шифер.
Ось у такому стані була вся покрівля. Посипалося, попадало все.
За роботою - Юрій разом із командою. До війни вони займалися ремонтами квартир і офісів.
Нині безкоштовно допомагають бучанцям, які не мають змоги платити.
Гроші на будматеріали збирають у соцмережах, а плату за роботу беруть лише,
якщо люди самі хочуть віддячити.
Коли ми вже вирішили допомагати своїми силами, то зрозуміли, що нам треба багато коштів на матеріали.
Враховуючи, що роботи зараз взагалі немає, ми згуртувалися, почали викидати пости в Instagram, Facebook.
І всі потроху почали скидати кошти, ми набрали коштів повністю на всю покрівлю, на метал.
Разом із будівельниками працює Владислав - онук власниці будинку.
Бабуся нині у родичів на Рівненщині, батьки виїхали.
Хлопець каже, що хоче відновити садибу якнайшвидше, але самотужки не впорався б.
Планую закінчити дах, тут деякі умови є, поки буду вирішувати з вікнами, думаю, бабуся зможе повернутися.
Там потихеньку вже будемо відбудовувати своїми силами.
Бабуся вже старенька. Вона вже не думала, що буде, куди повертатися.
Але врятували те, що залишилося.
Завдяки постам у соцмережах і допомозі знайомих Юрій з командою вже встановили кілька нових вікон і дверей.
Нині планують братися за ще один приватний будинок.
Це вперше в мене в житті, що я так збираю кошти.
Але ж ми - українці, ми ж сильна нація. Я так дивлюся, що люди одне одному допомагають.
Якщо будуть більше людей допомагати: хто може фізичною силою, хто може ті ж самі 50-100 гривень надсилати,
хто не може - якісь слова підтримки говорити - і все, цього достатньо, аби зробити якусь добру справу.
У самій лише Бучі, за даними міськради, зруйновані 22 висотних будинки, два з них не підлягають відновленню.
Майже вщент розбиті й 243 приватні садиби.
Тож будівельник Юрій каже: роботи вистачить ще надовго.